the people here especially some of these
hardcore feminist women I go they don't
they don't know nothing about this right
they complain about how horrible this
place is but think about it as a woman
in the United States you can go to
college you could have 90 cats nobody's
gonna say [ __ ] you could sleep with
everybody on the team you could get out
become a CEO you could do whatever you
could go on the streets March make up
with a girl take your clothes off burn
the flag say hashtag kill all men
nothing happens this poor girl her hat
was crooked and the morality police they
have [ __ ] morality police sorry for
my language beat her to death okay so
anytime I hear anybody complain
especially those feminists about this
place because Pat you nailed it they
don't know those who they don't they
don't know those stats and to be honest
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
so some from now on I'm not saying this
to those people that are just so
anti-america take a time out take a step
back look what's going on nobody knows
bro you can't have a dog that's like the
least one I thought you can't have it's
illegal to have a dog